Okay.
Good morning.
We're going to,
I'm going to show another movie today,
but no,
not tell a little bit later in the class.
We'll get it.
We'll get there.
Don't worry.
It doesn't,
it doesn't fit until,
until the,
the last part of the,
of the class.
Uh,
but today I want to
talk about sovereignty.
Uh,
there are two great concepts that come
out of hubs that you have to remember.
One is the state of nature
and the other is sovereignty.
Uh,
I spoke a bit about the first one,
uh,
yesterday or Monday rather.
Today I want to talk about Hobbs.
This theory of the sovereign,
the sovereign state.
Uh,
the creation of the sovereign Hobbs
refers to the sovereign is a mortal God is
his answer to the problems
of the state of nature,
the state,
the condition of life being solitary,
poor,
nasty,
brutish and short.
And it is only the creation of the
sovereign for Hobbes and Dowd or possessed
with absolute power that is sufficient
to put an end to the condition of
perpetual uncertainty,
anxiety and unrest.
That is the case of the natural condition.
Let me talk for a while about
some of the formal features of,
of Hobbs is sovereign power
of the hobby and state.
And the first place,
what I want to impress upon you is that
the sovereign is four hubs less a person
then it is or he is an office.
Uh,
the sovereign is described by Hobbs is
an artificial person by which he means
the sovereign is the creation
of the contract or the covenant.
Uh,
that brought this office into being.
The sovereign does not exist by nature,
but rather hubs tells us again,
the sovereignty is the
product of art or science.
He's the CO product,
the creation of the people or of what
we might call and Jeffersonian language.
He is a product of the
consent of the governed,
the sovereign,
and again,
this is crucial is for hubs.
The representative of the people.
He is the sovereign representative.
It is the people who endow the sovereign
with the authority to represent them on
their behalf.
Uh,
in a net respect,
Hobbs is sovereign,
has many of the features
or characteristics that we
come to associate with what
we call modern executive power.
Or Executive Authority when Louis,
the 14th of France famously said,
lay Todd saying why I am the state.
He was expressing a peculiarly
pre modern in that way,
conception of the stake.
That is to say he regarded the state
as in some ways his personal property.
I am the state,
I am the state [inaudible] but this is
very different from Hobbs is sovereign.
The s the state for Hobbes is not
the possession of the sovereign.
Rather the sovereign
does not own the state.
He is appointed or authorized
to secure for the people.
Uh,
the,
in many ways limited ends
of peace and security.
He has much the same
function and to some degree,
much of the same personality,
uh,
is what we would call a modern day CEO.
That is to say there is a kind of
anonymity in impersonality about the
sovereign.
I mean who,
I mean,
unless you're in the,
you know,
Yale Entrepreneurial Society who,
who can name the CEOs of many
companies and the answers,
you probably can't,
they are for the most part,
relatively anonymous,
uh,
individuals and less,
you know,
they get into trouble like Ken lay or
someone like that or do something amazing
like Bill Gates for the most part.
They are rather impersonal,
uh,
and,
and anonymous.
And that is in many ways the
characteristic of hubs is sovereign
hubs,
is theory of the sovereign,
interestingly,
contains within itself elements of both
secular absolutism and in some ways
modern liberalism.
And it is the tension between
these two that I want to bring out,
uh,
in,
in my discussion here.
The power of the sovereign
hubs continually insist,
must be unlimited.
Yet at the same time he's tells us that
the sovereign is the creation of the
people whom he represents
or it represents.
Uh,
although Hobbs is widely taken to be
a defender of monarchical absolutism,
you will note in your readings that he
displays a kind of studied neutrality,
uh,
over actually what form
does sovereign should take.
A,
he only insists that sovereign
power remain absolute and undivided,
whether it belongs to a single person,
a few,
uh,
or the many.
And among the powers that the sovereign,
uh,
he insists must control,
are for example,
laws concerning property,
the right,
uh,
of declaring war and peace,
what what we would call foreign policy,
uh,
rules of justice,
concerning life and death,
which is to say criminal law.
And of course the right to determine
what books and ideas are permissible.
That is to say,
uh,
the right,
of censorship.
In a sense.
The core of Hobbes is
theory of sovereignty can be
boiled down to the statement
that the sovereign and only the
sovereign is this source of law.
The law is what the sovereign says it is.
Does that sound in any way familiar
from what we have read this term?
Any anyone sound familiar?
[inaudible] do you remember that name?
Book One of the Republic Justice
is what this stronger say it is.
Hobbs tells us that the law is
what the sovereign commands.
This is sometimes known as the
doctrine of legal positivism,
which is to say that law is
the command of the sovereign.
I sort of command theory of law.
And again,
that seems to point back to a
Thrasymachus his point of view,
uh,
in the first book of the
Republic there is for Hobbes.
As for Thrasymachus,
no higher court of Appeal,
then the will or the
word of the sovereign,
no transcendent law,
no divine law and no source of authority
outside sovereign command sovereign is
appointed four hubs to
be much like an umpire,
uh,
in a baseball or a football game.
Just set the rules of the game.
But the Hobbsy and sovereign,
uh,
unlike umpires are not just the enforcers
of the rules or the interpreters of
the rules.
That sovereign is also the creator,
the shaper and maker,
uh,
of the rules and Hobbes draws from this,
the startling a conclusion in many ways,
the infamous conclusion that the
sovereign can never act unjustly.
Sovereign can never act unjustly.
Why?
Because the sovereign is the
source of law and this the source.
If the sovereign is the source
of the rules of justice,
therefore,
hubs concludes he can never act unjustly.
And he supports this example
by a deeply perverse and uh,
amusing.
I have to say,
reading from a biblical story.
Do you remember this?
He,
he refers to the story of David and Uriah.
Everybody will remember that story
from Sunday school or Hebrew school or
whatever.
Does anyone remember that David
was the king at that time?
He was the king of Israel and he
coveted Uriah as wife Bathsheba.
He wanted to sleep with Beth Sheba.
So what did he do?
He had Uriah killed so he could,
he could sleep with her.
And Hobbes reasons this story that while
David's action may have sinned against
God,
he did no injustice to Uriah.
Imagine that.
I think Uriah might've had a
different point of view about this.
Uh,
he did no injustice to Uriah
because as the lawful sovereign,
he could do any,
not just anything he liked,
but whatever he did was
the Wa was set by the,
by the rules of the law.
And when Hobbs tells that story,
which he,
which he mentions a couple
of times in the book,
one can only imagine.
He must've had a kind of
wry grin on his face when,
when,
when he,
when he wrote,
when he wrote that out.
In fact,
next semester I'm teaching an entire
course devoted to Hobbs as critique of
religion,
uh,
in which this will,
among other things figure prominently,
uh,
but Hobbs is teaching about law is in
some ways less draconian then then it
might at first appear,
he makes clear that law is
what the sovereign says it is.
There can be no such
thing as an unjust law.
He infers again,
because the sovereign is
the source of all justice,
but he does distinguish,
he tells us between
adjust law into good law,
all laws are by definition
just he tells us,
but it doesn't follow that.
All laws are by definition
good a good law.
He says chapter 30 is that which is
needful for the good of the people.
A good law is needful for
the good of the people.
But then he,
but then one asks,
what are the criteria by which we
determine the good of the people?
How was this determined?
And Hobbes makes clear that
the sovereign is not invested,
uh,
with the authority to exercise a kind
of absolute control over everything that
people do.
The,
the purpose of law Hobbes tells
us is not so much to control,
but to facilitate.
Consider just the following passage from
chapter 30 section 21 Hobbes rights for
the use of laws which
are but rules authorized,
he says,
is not to bind to the people
from all bow voluntary actions.
It is not to bind them
from voluntary actions,
but to direct and keep them in such
motion as not to hurt themselves by their
own impetuous desires,
rationalists or indiscretion as
hedges are set not to stop travelers,
but to keep them on their way.
This is the force or purpose of law to,
to set rules,
to keep people as he puts it on their way.
Uh,
a law that is intended simply to
constrain and control for its own sake.
Hobbes says cannot be a good law.
The purpose of a good law is to
facilitate human agency in some ways.
And I think again,
that too is central to Hobbs
is theory of the sovereign.
It's purpose is to facilitate
not simply to control,
uh,
and inhibit.
But the power to control or the power
of law for Hobbs also very much applies.
And here is one of his most,
uh,
um,
controversial doctrines.
It must certainly apply to
matters of opinion to what,
to what we would call today
first amendment issues.
Uh,
this is something that Hobbes
insists upon for the actions of men.
He says,
proceed from their opinions,
actions proceed from
opinions and in the end,
in the weld governing of opinions
consistent the weld governing of men's
actions.
So if we are,
if we are going to govern
or regulate human behavior,
we have to begin by regulating opinion.
And it follows from this.
Hobbes believes that the sovereign
has the right to decide what opinions,
what books,
what ideas are conducive to peace and
which ones aim simply to stir up war and
discontent
in these comments of hubs about the
sovereigns power to control opinions are
directed at two principal institutions,
the church.
And guess what the other one is
the university.
Both of these for Hobbs,
he considers to be locusts.
The focus of s or centers
of seditious opinion,
uh,
that required to remain under
sovereign control by the churches.
Uh,
Hobbs is speaking of the reformed church,
but in particular he is concerned
with those radical Puritan sect
of the type that later or can't came and
founded a America these radical sects
that elevate matters of conscience and
private belief over and above the law.
That is to say arrogating to themselves,
to the rights of conscience
in the private belief,
the powers to judge the sovereign.
It was these dissenting Protestants.
It was these dissenting sects formed
the rank and file of Cromwells armies.
Uh,
during the civil war in England.
They formed the rank and file of
the Republican armies in England,
uh,
against the rule of the king.
And Hobbes tells us he would banish
all doctrines that profess to make the
individual or the sect.
More importantly,
in some ways,
the sect,
the judge of the sovereign,
it is only in the state of nature.
He tells us that individuals have
the right to determine Justin unjust,
right and wrong for themselves.
Once we entered society,
once we engage or,
or conclude the social compact,
we transfer our power to
do this to the sovereign,
to determine,
uh,
these matters for us.
And just as important as the,
as the radical churches in the ref,
in the reforms.
Sex,
uh,
is four hubs of the university and its
curriculum in particular hubs is Fox,
the universities for teaching what?
For teaching the radical doctrines of
[inaudible] it in the 17th century.
Aristotle in this period was the
source of modern Republican ideas.
Ideas about self-government,
ideas about direct in some ways what
we might call direct democracy or
participatory democracy.
People who believe that the only
legitimate form of government is one where
Aristotle says citizens take turns
ruling and being ruled in turn,
it was above all the
influence of the classics,
the,
the Aristotle and Cicero in particular
that hubs regards as an important cause
for the recent civil war.
And the regicide of Charles,
the first considered the following
passage that he writes as to rebellion
against monarchy.
One of the most frequent causes is the
reading of the books of policy in history
of the ancient Greeks and Romans.
Reading of those books,
uh,
leads people to rebel against monarchy
for which young men like yourself,
he says,
or what young women to for which young
men and all others that are unprovoked
guided by the antidote of solid reason,
uh,
who are susceptible.
That is to reading these stories and
reading these books receive a strong and
delightful impression of
the great exploits of war.
Okay.
From reading of such books,
Hobbs continues.
Men have undertaken to kill their kings
because the Greek and Latin writers in
their books and discourses of policy make
it lawful and laudable for any man to
do so provided before he do it,
he called him a tyrant.
Okay.
Ah,
that's what you learn.
Hobbes believes from,
from the reading of Aristotle and
the Greeks enrollments regicide,
uh,
that the only legitimate form of
government is a republic and that it is a
lawful and even is your
duty to kill your king.
Uh,
of course,
before doing so,
he says you must call him first a tyrant.
Uh,
it's a wonderful passage
and this is so interesting,
I think not only because of its humor
and Hobbes is in many ways characteristic
exaggerations,
but because he shows,
it shows how much emphasis Hobbs
puts on the reform of opinion,
the reform of ideas in
many ways like Machiavelli,
unlike Plato to before him,
hubs regards himself as
an educator of princes,
an educator of in a transformer,
a reformer of ideas.
There was a kind of internal irony here
I think because hubs sometimes writes as
if,
as we've seen as if human beings are
nothing more than complex machines that
mechanically obey the laws
of attraction and repulsion.
But he also obviously writes that we
are beings with will and purpose who are
uniquely guided by opinions,
ideas and doctrines.
And it is in many ways the first business
of the sovereign to act as a moral
reformer of ideas.
Hubs realizes this is a difficult and
uphill task that he has set for himself.
And in a rare moment of,
of sort of personal self
reflection or self reference,
he notes,
uh,
somewhat,
drolly that the novelty of his ideas,
uh,
will make it difficult for
them to find an audience.
Uh,
I am at the point of believing,
he says this might,
that my labor will be as useless
is the Commonwealth of Plato.
Okay.
He says in a moment of sort
of uncharacteristic despair
will be as useless as
the Commonwealth of Plato.
For Plato,
he says also is of the opinion that it
is impossible for the disorders of the
state ever to be taken away
till sovereigns be philosophers.
And while in many ways
initially despairing of the
possibility of finding a sort
of friendly reception or audience
for his work hubs then goes on in a,
in a more optimistic note to observe
that his book is considerably simpler and
easier to read than Plato's.
Okay.
Can you might have a discussion
about that over which witches?
The easier one.
But Hobbes believes it is simpler and
easier and therefore more likely to catch
the ear of a sympathetic prince.
I recover some hope.
He says,
I recover some hope
that one time or other,
this writing of mine may fall into the
hands of a sovereign who will consider it
for himself for it is short.
And I think Claire,
well,
we might question that he says it's
a short book and I think clear.
He writes,
well,
it's complex and long,
but nevertheless,
uh,
perhaps hoping that his advertising
it in this way will gain the ear of a
sovereign and that without the help,
he continues of any interested
or envious interpreter.
And by the exercise of entire in
protecting the public teaching of it,
convert this truth of speculation
into the utility of practice.
The very end of chapter 31,
uh,
we'll convert this truth of speculation
into the utility of practice.
So Hobbes clearly believes he or thinks
that this will be a useful book for a
sovereign to read and hope,
hoping it will gain the
ear of a sympathetic,
a sovereign or potential sovereign.
Uh,
Hobbes may I think,
overestimate a,
or maybe I really should say
underestimate the difficulty of the book.
Uh,
but he returns to this again
at the very end of Leviathan,
the universities,
he says that where he talks again a little
bit about the audience for the book.
The universities he says are the
fountains of civil and moral doctrine,
the universities or the fountains of
civil and moral doctrines and have the
obligation to,
to teach the correct doctrine
of rights and duties.
And this means for Hobbes.
First of all,
adopting his book is the authoritative
teaching on moral and political doctrine
in the universities.
This should be the required
textbook of political science,
of political teaching in the universities
to replace the older textbook,
I.
E.
Aristotle's politics.
Therefore,
he says,
I think it may be profitably printed
and more profitably taught in the
universities.
He confidently,
uh,
asserts the ideal audience for the book.
He says,
should be the preachers,
the Gentry,
the lawyers.
Men have affairs who drawing such water
as they find from the book can use it.
He says to sprinkle the same,
both from the pulpit and from
their conversation upon the people.
This is how he sees it.
That it should be taught from the pulpit.
It should be taught from the universities
and from this conversation will be
sprinkled upon the people hubs is hope
like that of all the great political
philosophers was to be a kind
of legislator for mankind.
This again is a book with,
with epic,
epic ambition.
Okay.
Let me mention,
uh,
I've emphasized that in many ways the
absolutist and authoritarian side of Hobbs
is teaching.
Let me talk about something
that might sound oxymoronic.
Let me call it for the moment.
Hobbsy and liberalism
hubs enjoys describing the sovereign
in the most absolute and extreme term.
Sovereign is to have supreme
command over life and death,
war and peace.
What is to be taught and
yeah.
And yet in many ways
that's the hubs again,
sovereign aims to allow for ample
room for individual liberty.
And even he even set some limits,
uh,
under legitimate use of sovereign
power for all of his tough talk.
Uh,
Hobbes takes justice and the
rule of law very seriously,
uh,
far more seriously than for example,
does.
Machiavelli,
that's it.
One time in the book or one point,
he maintains that a person cannot be
made to accuse themselves without the
assurance of pardon.
You can't be forced to accuse yourself
what we would call the fifth amendment.
You cannot be forced to accuse yourself.
Similarly,
he says,
a wife or a parent cannot be coerced
to accuse a loved one and an a similar
point.
He maintains that punishment can never
be used as an instrument of revenge,
but only for what he calls the
correction or what we would call the
rehabilitation,
uh,
of the,
of the offender.
Add to the above.
Hobbes is repeated insistence that lost
serve as an instrument for achieving
social equality.
In a chapter called of the office
of the sovereign representative,
Hobbes argues that justice be equally
administered to all classes of people rich
as well as poor.
The equal application of justice.
He maintains further,
the titles of nobility are a value,
uh,
only,
for the benefits they confer on those
of lesser rank or they're not useful at
all.
Equal justice.
He tells us requires equal taxation
policy and he seems to be proposing a kind
of consumption tax so that the,
the rich who consume more,
we'll have to pay their fair share when
he argues that indigent citizens who are
unable to provide for themselves should
not be forced to rely simply upon the
private charity of individuals,
but should be maintained
at public expense.
He seems in this way to anticipate what
we might think of as the modern welfare
state that,
uh,
that,
public,
uh,
assistance be provided and the poor
are not simply depend on the private
goodwill,
uh,
of,
of their others.
Okay.
But most importantly,
I think is to go back to the individual.
The importance given to the
individual in Hobbs is philosophy.
Hobbes derives the very power of the
sovereign from the natural right of each
individual to do as they
like in the state of nature.
And it follows,
I think,
uh,
that the purpose of the sovereign is
really to safeguard the natural right of
each individual,
but to regulate this right.
Uh,
so that it becomes consistent
with the right of others.
And not simply,
again,
a kind of open war against
all of all against all.
What is significant about this I think
is the priority that Hobbes gives to
rights over duties.
This in many ways arguably
makes him the founding father,
or maybe we should say
godfather of modern liberalism,
the,
the importance given to rights over
duties of the individual over in many ways
the collective or common good.
And I think this is
expressed in Hobbs is novel.
Uh,
and in many ways altogether unprecedented
teaching about liberty in chapter 21
very famous and important chapter.
And here he distinguishes
the liberty of the,
what he calls the liberty
of the ancients or what,
what he doesn't exactly call,
but I'll call the liberty of the
ancients and the liberty of the moderns.
The ancients,
he believes operated with a defective
understanding of human freedom.
For the ancients,
liberty meant,
uh,
living in a self governing republic liver
living in a republic in which everyone
again took some share
in the ruling offices.
Liberty.
In other words,
for the ancients was not just
a property of the individual.
It was an attribute of
the regime of which one,
uh,
of which one was a member.
The Athenians and the Romans,
he says,
we're free.
That is they were free.
Commonweal's.
Not that any particular man had the
liberty to resist his own representative,
but that his representative had the
liberty to resist or invade other people.
In other words,
liberty for the ancients
was a collective good.
The,
the liberty,
as he says,
to resist or invade other people.
It was a property of the Commonwealth,
not of the individuals
who who inhabited it,
but that sense of collective liberty.
Uh,
the freedom to resist or invade is not an,
is in fact even opposed to the modern
idea of liberty that Hobbs proposes.
And by Liberty Hobbs means it's something
that sounds very familiar to us.
Liberty means the absence of
constraints or impediments to action.
We are free to the extent that we
can act in an unimpeded manner.
And it follows from him that political,
political liberty means the freedom to
act where the law is silent as he says.
Think of that,
that where the law is silent,
we have the freedom to do
or not to do as we choose.
Very important to the way we think
of liberty today in a modern,
now you might say liberal democracy,
Hobbes is sovereign,
is more likely to allow citizens as zone
of private liberty where they are free
to act as they choose.
Then in the classical republic where
there is a kind of coerced participation,
uh,
in collective affairs or in political
deliberation and Hobbes here takes a dig
at the defenders of the view in his own
day that only the citizens of a republic
can be free.
Okay.
There is written,
he says,
and the tourists of the
city of Luca and anybody,
let me just ask before
I continue this passage.
Anybody here in Pearson College?
So you know,
you all know that the dean,
Mr Amerigo,
yeah,
you're doing,
your dean is from the city of Lucca.
Ask him if this is true.
Uh,
when you see them there is written and
the tourists of the city of Lucca in
great characters,
meaning great letters at this day.
The word Libertas Libertas has written
on the walls of the tourists of the city
of Luca
is find out if that's still true yet.
No Man Hubs Can,
continues convince,
infer consents in furthered a particular
man has more liberty or immunity from
the service of the Commonwealth
there then in Constantinople,
the city of the Caliphs,
the caliphate living in a republic alone
doesn't guarantee you more freedom.
He says freedom in that
interesting passage.
Freedom here requires as he puts it,
immunity,
immunity from service.
A regime is to be judged for
Hobbes on how much private liberty,
how much immunity it grants each of its
citizens and idea of individual liberty
in many ways unknown and
unprecedented in the,
in the modern world.
And in this respect,
one can say that Hobbs has some connection
to the creation of what we think of
as the modern liberal state with
its conception of private freedom,
as immunity from forced co
forced participation or forced,
uh,
participation in,
in politics,
very different from the ancients.
So what does this all mean?
Uh,
let me talk about what Hobbs
has to say for us today.
We who have in many ways
become hubs as children
hubs gives us the definitive
language of the modern state,
yet he remains in many ways,
is contested for us as
he was in his own time.
For many today,
Hobbs is conception of the Leviathan
state is synonymous with anti-liberal
absolutism.
And yet for others,
he opened the door to John Locke and
the liberal theory of government.
He talked the priority of rights over
duties and he argued that the sovereign
should serve the lowly interest or
the lowly ends of providing peace and
security,
leaving it to individuals to determine
for themselves how best to live their
lives.
Nonetheless,
the liberty that subjects,
the subjects in joy in Hobbs
is plan falls in that area.
That the simply that he says the sovereign
omit to regulate hubs does not craze
vigilance in defense of liberty.
And he denounces all efforts
to resist the government.
It best one could say Hobbes is a
kind of part time liberal at best,
but Hobbs is best when he
is providing us with the,
in many ways the moral and psychological
language in which we think about
government and the state.
The state is a product of a psychological
struggle between the contending
passions of pride and fear.
Fear you remember,
is associated with the
desire for security order,
rationality and peace.
Pride is connected with the love of glory,
honor,
recognition and ambition.
All the goods of civilization hubs tells
us stem from our ability to control
pride.
The very title of the book comes from
this wonderful biblical passage from Joe
where Leviathan is described as
king of the children of pride.
And the 19 laws of nature that hubs,
uh,
IX develops in his book.
Uh,
really are there simply to enumerate or
instruct us about the virtues of socio
ability and civility,
uh,
especially directed against
the sin of pride or Hubris.
So the modern state is,
we know it and still have it in many ways,
grew out of the hubs,
Ian Desire for security and the fear of
death that can only be achieved at the
expense of the desire for honor and glory.
The Hobbsy and state was intended
to secure the conditions of life,
uh,
even a highly civilized
and cultivated life,
but one calculated in terms of
self interest and risk avoidance
hubs wants us to be fearful and to avoid
dangerous courses of action that are,
are,
are inflamed by beliefs and honor,
ambition and the like.
The Hobbsy and fearful man is not likely
to become someone who risks life for
liberty for honor or for a cause is more
likely to be someone who plays by the
rules,
avoids dangers and bets
on the shore thing.
The Hobbs and citizen is not likely to
be a risk taker like a George Washington
or Andrew Carnegie is more likely to
think like an actuary or a CPA or an
insurance agent.
Always calculating the odds and
finding ways to cover the damages.
Later,
political theorists like John Jacques
Rousseau in Nicha would even develop a
word for Hobbsy and man,
they would call him
somewhat contemptuously,
the bourgeois.
But nevertheless,
Hobbs was remarkably successful in
converting us to his point of view,
the type of individual he tried to create,
careful self interested,
risk averse.
This is become the dominant ethos
of our civilization has has it not.
We even have entire disciplines like
economics and psychology and I dare even
say modern political science that
reinforce this view of human nature.
We have all become,
whether we choose to admit it or not,
Hobbes,
eons.
And yet at the same time,
and here is the paradox,
I think even a HUBZone and society
cannot entirely exist without some
individuals who are willing
to risk life and limb,
uh,
either for the sake of honor,
for self respect,
or even just from the sheer joy
that comes from risk itself.
Remember my example on
Monday of Ralph Esposito?
Why do people become firemen,
policemen,
soldiers,
freedom fighters,
all activities that cannot be explained
in terms of self interest alone will not
even a Hobbsy in society,
again,
require fire departments.
And where will people come from
that if they all follow that?
The psychology of fear and self interest
that Hobbes wants to instill in US
Hobbes regards to these passions.
What Plato called by the
word fool most played up,
Hobbes regarded these passions
in many ways is barbaric,
uncivilized and warlike.
And to some degree he would,
he was right
even though,
but even the HUBZone and state Hobbes
admits himself the hubs and state lives in
the midst of a HUBZone and world.
That is to say the world of
international relations is four hubs.
The simply the state of nature writ large,
the hubs and,
and state will always exist in
a world of hostile other states,
unregulated by some kind of higher loss
state stand to one another on the world
stage as individuals do in
the condition of nature.
That is to say potential enemies with no
higher authority by which to adjudicate
their conflicts.
And in such a world,
even a sovereign state will be endangered
either from other states or from
groups and individuals devoted
to terror and destruction.
Uh,
think of September 11th,
2001,
uh,
this is a problem that profound political
scientist by the name of Prs Nair,
uh,
a French student of Internet international
politics has described as the
dialectic of the bourgeois
and the barbarian.
A struggle that is to say between the
modern Hobbsy in state with its largely
pacified and satisfied citizen bodies
and those pre modern states or maybe in
some ways even postmodern states that
are prepared to use the instruments of
violence,
terror and suicide bombings
to achieve their goals.
Uh,
Hobbsy in state,
paradoxically still
requires from its citizens,
uh,
men and women prepared to fight to risk
everything in the defense of their way
of life.
But the hubs,
Ian,
the point,
the paradox being that the hubs,
the and bourgeois cannot entirely
dispense with the barbarian,
uh,
even in its own mist mist.
Can Hobbs explain this paradox?
He seems to avoided this
problem has been brought out,
I think brilliantly.
Uh,
in a recent book by a
man named James Bowman,
uh,
a book called honor a history,
he wrote a history of honor.
And here he points out that while affairs
of honor is they are quaintly called
have largely disappeared
from advanced societies.
That honors still remains a consuming
passion in many parts of the world today,
including for him.
Most importantly,
the Middle East
honor in most societies is thought to
be not merely a personal quality like
something like medieval chivalry,
but is above all group honor.
The honor that surrounds the family,
the extended clan or the religious sect
and assault on one is an assault on all.
This helps us to explain for instance,
why in so many,
uh,
the concept of saving
face is so important,
even if to most modern Americans,
it seems relatively trivial.
Uh,
in one reason Boehm and
believes this is that we,
that we have such a difficult time in
understanding other peoples and other
cultures is that the very idea of
defending one's honor has largely been
devalued.
Uh,
in the modern west,
uh,
we tend to look at human behavior as a
matter of providing rational incentives
for human action.
Why most people in fact are driven by a
need for esteem and the desire to avoid
humiliation.
I remember,
for example,
during the Vietnam War when
Richard Nixon spoke about,
uh,
achieving peace with honor,
and this was largely marked
as a kind of ludicrous,
uh,
idea,
honor to so many of us sounds quaint,
like an honor code or the boy scouts
a code or something like that,
or something primitive,
some kind of primitive ethic,
uh,
which we therefore
don't really understand.
Uh,
we don't often see that
it was in large parts.
Hubs is efforts to
discredit this kind of war.
Your virtue,
this kind of virtue of honor.
Uh,
that is so a part,
so much a part of cultures,
uh,
that is,
is also responsible for
our current blindness.
And that brings me to my final point
about our hubs and civilization that
conceals from us a very
uncomfortable truth,
peace,
the peace,
security and safety,
what we might call our bourgeois
freedoms that we enjoy.
Rest on the fact,
on the uncomfortable fact that there are
people still people who are willing to
risk their lives for the sake of
higher goals like honor or duty.
Is that irrational for them to do so?
Hubs would believe it is.
I think he would say yes.
It doesn't make sense from a purely Hobbsy
and point of view that encourage us.
It encourages us to think like rational
actors interested mainly in safety and
beating the odds.
Hubs in many ways finds himself in the
position of the young military lawyer
played in the following movie clip.
I'm going to show you,
okay,
this is the point made the point is
made then I will not even provide any
further commentary on what I know.
I only apologized it for some
reason I couldn't get the picture.